de lo que quiero platicar en este vídeo
es de las diferentes formas de medir la
cantidad de dinero que tenemos en
circulación todo empieza con el banco
central el banco central en el caso de
méxico sería el banco de méxico- y
supongamos que el banco central imprime
cuatro billetes de 100 pesos favorita
por visualización vamos a pensar que
solo son billetes físicos también podría
ser dinero electrónico pero ahorita es
puro dinero físico sale entonces la
forma en la cual el banco de méxico-
mete esto en circulación es que con
estos 400 pesos compran valores en el
mercado abierto usualmente son valores
muy seguros y muy líquidos líquido
quiere decir que es muy fácil vender y
comprar por ejemplo los valores
gubernamentales es algo que es muy fácil
de comprar y vender sin embargo si
compraras digamos un millón de pesos en
maracas pues sería muy difícil comprar y
vender ese millón de pesos en maracas
entonces pues estaría muy difícil tanto
comprarlos como venderlos entonces las
maracas no son un activo líquido saleh
no se pueden comprar ni vender
fácilmente en un corto mediano plazo
pero bueno y el banco central compra
pues digamos un valor gubernamental de
400 pesos este de aquí
y la persona a quien le compran este
valor entonces lo va a depositar en un
banco bueno a lo mejor no lo deposita
directamente a lo mejor se lo gasta se
lo da a alguien más pero esa otra
persona pues va a obtener ese dinero y
no se podemos pensar que eventualmente
esos billetes van a acabar en un banco
estoy aquí es un banco banco privado
número 1 así le vamos a poner entonces
estos cuatro billetes están aquí adentro
están transferidos en este banco en el
banco privado número uno
400 ya no están acá verdad ya no están
en el banco de méxico ya no están en el
banco central
entonces los voy a tachar navas para
dejar bien claro esto le voy a poner
unas flechitas
sale entonces ya están depositados en el
banco privado número 1 y ahora
supongamos que la persona que los
depositó dice sabes que necesito tres de
estos a la vista porque voy a escribir
algunos cheques y entonces estos tres de
acá van a acabar en una cuenta de
cheques deja escribo algo aquí para
acordarnos puede escribir cheques por
hasta
hasta 300 pesos ok entonces esto de acá
quedó en una cuenta de cheques pero lo
de acá arriba lo va a poner en una
cuenta de ahorros para tener más interés
y el banco claro que va estar de acuerdo
porque va a poder prestarlo así pues sin
tantas presiones y entonces por este
dinero no se van a poder escribir
cheques bueno si hay algunas
circunstancias en las que si se puede
pero por simplicidad vamos a pensar que
no se puede o bien que hay pues muchas
restricciones
entonces este banco va a decir va okay
este billete de 100 ahorita no lo tengo
que mantener en reservas lo puedo
prestar se lo prestan a alguien y
supongamos que el banco cae perdón el
billete cae en otro banco que hay acá en
el banco privado número 2 que ahorita
voy a dibujar deja tacho el billete
primero entonces ya no está en el banco
uno va al banco 2 este de acá que está
en color blanco muy bien estoy aquí es
el banco privado número 2 y aquí está el
billete supongamos que una vez más la
persona lo deposita en una cuenta de
ahorros y digamos que de estos tres el
banco dice sabes que esto de acá está a
la vista pero como estoy en un sistema
bancario de reserva fraccionaria
entonces si puedo prestar una parte
cuánto puede prestar pues depende del
requisito de coeficiente de reserva que
establezca el sistema pero aquí por
simplicidad supongamos que nada más
presta dos tercios entonces presta dos
de estos billetes que le llegan a
alguien más y ese alguien digamos que
por pura casualidad también los deposita
en el banco privado número
entonces los billetes quedan por aquí
los billetes ya no están en el banco
privado número uno déjalo estar
y ojo esta persona todavía puede
escribir cheques por 300 pesos ahora
vayamos al banco privado número 2 y
supongamos que esto quede en una cuenta
de cheques entonces quedan en una cuenta
de cheques del banco privado número 2 y
ahora el banco número 2 puede hacer
varias cosas pues en esta cuenta de
cheques de aquí abajo debe de mantener
un poquito en reservas digamos que es un
poco más conservador y entonces nada más
presta a la mitad podría prestar hasta
el 90 por ciento pero nada más va a
prestar la mitad presta este billete de
aquí estos 100 pesos y la persona que
pidió el préstamo los guarda en su
cartera entonces ya lo guarde en su
cartera este de acá que está en una
cuenta de ahorros también lo puede
prestar se lo presta lo tachó de aquí y
le voy a poner que también se va a la
cartera de alguien entonces esto es una
cartera va observa los cuatro billetes
originales 34 billetes todavía están ahí
y bueno para ser muy claros esta persona
puede escribir cheques por hasta 300
pesos y esta persona de acá puede
escribir cheques
escribir dejar lo pongo en el color de
las cuentas de cheques en color rosa
puede escribir cheques por hasta 200
pesos muy bien ahora vamos a pensar un
poquito en las distintas formas de
dinero que hay aquí podemos pensar en
dinero de una forma muy muy estrecha
simplemente es cuánto dinero imprimió en
el banco central o cuánto creó
electrónicamente otra vez pues ahorita
dijimos que nos vamos a enfocar nada más
en el dinero físico en puros billetes a
esta noción de dinero se le conoce como
base monetaria aleja le escribo por acá
base monetaria y en méxico y en otros
países también se le conoce como m 0 la
definición precisa de m 0 depende un
poquito del país pero en este ejemplo es
bastante más sencillo en cuanto imprimen
estos billetes que meten en circulación
pues tenemos 400 pesos de base monetaria
es bastante razonable pensar esto como
dinero verdad porque en cuanto se
compran los valores y entra el dinero en
circulación esos cuatro billetes de esos
cuatrocientos pesos se pueden utilizar
para hacer transacciones
ahora claramente eso no es todo lo que
se puede utilizar para hacer
transacciones en este pequeño universo
este cuate o sea están los 400 pesos
pero estas personas también pueden
escribir cheques y con esos cheques
pagar cosas entonces vamos a pensar en
una definición un poco más amplia de
dinero que le pondremos m1 hay varias
formas de pensar la una es simplemente
como todo el dinero que está en los
bolsillos de las personas más todo el
dinero que se pueda escribir en cheques
si lo vemos de esta forma serían estos
dos billetes de 100 más 500 pesos que se
pueden escribir en cheques y así en
total tendríamos 200 pesos en las
carteras de las personas verdad no en
los bancos más 500 pesos que se pueden
escribir en cheques 500 pesos que sería
en total 700 pesos esa es una forma de
pensarlo pero otra forma de pensarlo es
como m cero más lo que se puede escribir
por cheque es lo que está en cuentas de
cheques le voy a poner cuentas de
cheques pero si haces eso ahora estás
contando dos veces algo verdad porque un
poquito de lm cero es reservas entonces
tenemos que descontar algo de aquí de
hecho lo que estamos contando dos veces
es justo las reservas entonces tenemos
que restar
las reservas bancarias las reservas
bancarias muy bien entonces tendríamos a
ver cuántos serían pues l m 0 es 400
pesos fija lo pongo en color no éste no
acercó lo que quiero dejar lo pongo en
color blanco entonces serían m 0 que es
400 pesos más lo que está en cuentas de
cheques que son 300 más 200 son 500
pesos voy a ponerlo en color rosa más
500 pesos pero luego tenemos que restar
las reservas que hay dos billetes son
200 pesos en reservas menos 200 pesos
esto de aquí otra vez nos da 700 pesos
lo cual es bueno y justo hicimos esto
para no contar dos veces las reservas
verdad si contamos esto como lm cero y
también lo contamos como la cuenta de
cheques entonces estamos contando ese
dinero dos veces y no queremos hacer eso
sí verdad sí está bien porque está en la
base monetaria y en las cuentas de
cheques pero se repiten las reservas y
por eso lo restamos pero bueno la forma
más sencilla es la primera el m1 es con
lo que se puede hacer transacciones en
este momento o sea los 200 pesos en el
bolsillo y los 500 pesos para escribir
cheques
esto que acabo de decir es esta cuenta
de por acá va si queremos pensar un poco
más ampliamente podemos pensar en m2 y
m2 es número uno lo que se puede
utilizar inmediatamente para hacer
transacciones
es decir el m1 aquí están los 700 pesos
de m1 pero a eso le sumamos todo lo que
se puede convertir fácilmente en m 1 por
ejemplo estas cuentas de ahorros se
pueden convertir fácilmente en cuentas
de cheques digo puede tomar algunos días
o puede haber algunas restricciones pero
se puede convertir una vez que se
convierta hay que hacer ciertas
consideraciones por los requisitos de
reserva pero bueno va a permitir que
esta persona puede escribir cheques por
mayores cantidades
entonces m 12m uno más las cosas que se
pueden convertir fácilmente am-1 déjame
le pongo cuentas de ahorros cuentas de
ahorros también digamos cuentas de
dinero en el mercado ahorita no me voy a
meter mucho en eso son similares tienes
un poco más de interés pero más
restricciones pero igual no es tan
difícil convertirlas en cuentas de
cheques y no sé cosas como certificados
de depósito en cantidades pequeñas y a
corto plazo en este ejemplo como es muy
sencillito sólo son cuentas de ahorros
entonces serían los 700 de lm
700 pesos de uno más 200 pesos que están
en cuenta de cheques 200 pesos sería en
total 900 pesos ok entonces nada más
esto es para darte una idea de que
cuando alguien te platica acerca de la
oferta de dinero te tiene que aclarar a
qué se refiere lo más típico es el m1
porque esto se puede usar así
directamente para hacer transacciones ya
sabes escribir cheques o bien billetes
que están en las carteras de las
personas pero también podrían estar
refiriéndose a la base monetaria a m0
que es lo mismo en méxico y en otros
países o bien podrían estar hablando de
algo un poco más amplio no sé por
ejemplo en vez de estar hablando de m2
podrían estar hablando de m3 que es un
poco más amplia porque esa de ahí
contempla pues otro tipo de activos que
están un poco más alejados del efectivo
y de las cuentas de cheques pero que
siguen siendo bastante líquidos bueno de
cualquier forma ya no se usa tanto el m3
en eeuu por ejemplo lo dejaron de
reportar hace algunos años también hay
m4 y también lo dejaron de reportar pero
típicamente sm1 y m2